[Music]
[Applause]
Peter King is Back 40 years covering the
NFL
40 years football morning in America
columnist nbcsports.com Peter joins us
now Pete 40 years 40 years I had the
under but uh congratulations on 40 years
how have training camps changed like the
biggest change has been won
you know access
uh you know two quick examples I used to
my first year covering the Cincinnati
Bengals
in Wilmington Ohio that's where training
camp was the port capital of Ohio by the
way
and every year in the parade in downtown
Wilmington they crowned a pork Queen
but uh anyway I actually did go to that
parade but
um so
at that training camp I watch practice
I'd say at least half the day
and we had a freeze up there with Peter
see if we need to reconnect there Todd
we will reconnect all right yeah Peter
Peter's Frozen in Time there crushing
that yes he was he was Timeless really
yes he is yes he is 40 years is uh Peter
back with us Todd he is back with us on
the phone okay all right Pete you were a
mid-story about the Bengals training
camp in uh Wilmington Ohio in the pork
queen as well yeah and uh so I watched
practice with Paul Brown almost I don't
know at least half the days I I covered
the team that was a little bit different
next year I go to Latrobe for the first
time to see the Steelers in Camp and the
pr guy the venerable Joe Gordon says uh
who do you want to talk to I said a
couple of guys like to talk to Mike
Webster and he said just go over to room
135 of the player's door knock on the
door he'll answer it and I walked in
Mike Webster's room talked to him for 45
minutes
those uh times have changed a little bit
Dan Peter has visited the jet Steelers
Lions bills and uh speaking of the Jets
I put the over under
for Aaron Rodgers career with the Jets
at two and a half years
that's a good one what would you take
over
okay because I'll tell you exactly why
you know we had a conversation about
what he did with his contract
okay because then when quarterbacks and
when players rewrite their contracts
they always do it to eventually get up
uh you know and get essentially the same
amount of money they just arrange it
differently Aaron Rodgers is getting
upwards of 30 million dollars less and
he agreed to do that and one of the
things that he told me was essentially
he said look I I am I I want to show
these people that I'm gonna be here for
a while and what I really want to do is
I want to help us let's say at the
trading deadline
I really want to help us uh get players
and and so I think he thinks of this
uh as more than you know we've we've
said Jesus you're only going to be there
one year no he's of course he's going to
be there at least two
but I would say more than that he was
talking about how good he feels he
talked a lot about Tom Brady's training
and physical regimen he's given up sugar
and uh almost everything in terms of
processed food and so he's playing Brady
right now and I think he wants to play
not just to the age of 40 but well into
his 40s could you see a scenario and I
know this is obviously hypothetical but
all goes well they win the Super Bowl
Aaron Rodgers walks away
I
I know who knows I don't you know
you don't know Aaron Rodgers I've talked
I talked to him twice a year let's say
okay we had a good conversation but I
don't know him the way I've known some
other players he's very much a uh
there's a fence up there and he you know
he likes that he likes his privacy likes
his other life
uh so no I I I have no idea but
I do think that if he wins it all he may
reconsider the one thing I do know he's
told me a couple of times he really
wants to see the world
you know I think he would like the way
Larry Fitzgerald did you know he's been
to like 98 countries I I think Aaron
Rodgers could would really get into that
when he stops playing football talking
to Peter King football morning in
America columnist he's back and this is
uh his 40th year covering NFL training
camps and then you had the matchup with
the Jets and Broncos week five with
Aaron Rodgers and Sean Payton what was
your reaction to Sean Payton's comments
to USA Today
I mean it was way over the top I thought
it I I couldn't believe it I there's no
purpose served to do that in my opinion
and I think once the genie was out of
the bottle Sean and I'm sure uh the
Broncos excellent PR guy uh Patrick
Smythe realized you got to do something
about this and so he did he tried to but
then I was we were driving from with uh
from Latrobe to actually to Port Clinton
Ohio to have dinner on Friday night and
then on to Detroit
uh after Steelers camp and I got a phone
call from a coach who just said he broke
the code
he broke the code and uh he uh he said
if you talk to Salah urge him to not
accept an apology so easily but you know
what style is not a warm sala's not a
war Monger I think he I think assuming
that the call will happen or maybe has
happened over the weekend
I think Peyton will totally uh
capitulate and say oh sorry is and Salah
May challenge him a bit but I don't
think Sal is going to make this a war
Mike Tomlin said something funny though
to me he goes man then all I know is
that I hope that that game the Denver
Jets game is on national TV maybe at a
time where everybody can watch it
because I want to watch that football
game right now I think it's a 425 game
and uh yeah yeah so I don't know if
Michael will be doing a one o'clock game
or another one but a lot of people get
an opportunity to see that uh Jimmy say
he loves to think out loud and in this
situation like what did he put himself
into with Jonathan Taylor do you think
big picture with his comments
I mean that's another case of
and I think look I I think jimmers say
is
a very very for those who don't know him
he's a very good-hearted person he loves
his team
all he did was answer a question
honestly about hey your problem isn't
with us it's with your union if you want
to fix the franchise tag you got to
fight for it but why would we give up
uh stuff we got on the franchise tag and
stuff in this new agreement and
voluntarily pay a position that isn't
paid very well
twice or three times as much as the
average now just because you think
you're worth it
and look
it was probably time to lower the
temperature and maybe have no comment no
question about it he didn't help but I
read his comments and and look it was
not the right time to say it but I read
his comments and I said he's just simply
stating a fact
oh yeah but I mean he is but I don't
know what that factor is going to lead
to as far as I don't know how it helps I
it doesn't it doesn't help and so I
would not have done it but I don't think
it was all together that controversial
the timing of it was just it was just a
bad time to to say that when you know
that one of your huge stars is butt hurt
over the whole thing why are we so
optimistic on the Detroit Lions
because
I think when a team finishes eight and
two when a team fixes the defense that
was so awful the first half of the
season
and we think they fixed the defense when
they have some very very good young
players especially on the front seven
Aiden Hutchinson James Houston
um look I feel the same way as you
I think there's a chance this is 28-3 at
halftime in the opening game however
I think that the NFL and putting the
game there which was to me the biggest
surprise of the whole schedule uh
process I think the NFL went putting the
game there said Dan Campbell we trust
you Jared Goff Ben Johnson America
doesn't know this Ben Johnson but I'm
telling you the offensive coordinator
the Lions he'll be a head coach in the
NFL I don't know when sometime key is
really really smart it's like he fell
off the uh the Sean McVay tree uh even
though he didn't and and I just I think
he's really bright and you're going to
hear a lot about him and I think he's
been a godsend for Jared he saved Jared
goff's career or helped save Pierre
goff's career
um
Joe Burrows situation they said out a
few weeks uh any concern there cause for
concern
of course
you know look you if you were positive
that Joe burrow is going to play the
opener against Cleveland
and you were sure that he was going to
be 100 for that game and no worries but
that is a weird injury
you know a strained calf depending on
the level of strain
uh if it's not all better
let's just say he's going and trying to
run away from Miles Garrett on September
10th he they could be in trouble because
if this injury somehow someway lingers
um yeah the Bengals are going to finish
third or fourth in that Division and so
you know he is
I I think yes I do think there's cause
to be to be worried the only good thing
for them is when you have six weeks
before you play a game that matters that
seemingly is enough time to get this
right it's just if Joe burrow enters the
season 89 or something like that and he
re-aggravates it you know it's wait till
2024 for the Bengals how much pressure
are the Buffalo Bills under
I think a lot but I was there yesterday
and you can't feel it it's like aldermar
Hamlin all the time it's it's amazing
there
uh where Demar Hamlin has gone from
being
someone who no one really knew on gene
on at noon on January 2nd two days later
he's on the back page of the New York
Post with a screaming headline America's
son
and now I would say Dan I'll ask you
this question I'd say he's one of the 10
most famous people in the NFL today
and I I'd ask you this question who's
more famous in the United States right
now Lamar Jackson former MVP of the NFL
or Demar Hamlin oh Demar Hamlin because
that story crossed over so every
football fan knows both of them but your
wife or your mother you know Damar
Hamlin right that's right and so Dan you
know what was really interesting
yesterday at camp
when I watched post practice
Demar Hamlin had a line of people
waiting for him family friends and all
that stuff not only does he sign a lot
of autographs but you know when you go
to Bill's camp and you're the nephew of
the strength coach you want to meet
Demar and so Demar was just there I I
counted 35 minutes
afterwards that he was just meeting
posing signing hugging babies you know
and and I I walked away and I said to
somebody there you know Josh Allen is 1A
and and will be for the foreseeable
future he is and rightfully so a beloved
figure in that Community
uh and but Demar Hamlin is close right
now and you know Dan the weird thing and
I don't expect him to get cut I I really
don't but right now he's fighting for
the fourth safety job in that camp
you know Micah hi Jordan poyer and they
signed Taylor Rapp from the Rams in free
agency and he's a pretty solid at number
three and remember Demar Hamlin played
last year but only because of an injury
to the mic to uh I'm sorry to uh Micah
Hyde so that's what you have to look out
for and again I do not think they're
going to cut them however I do think I
would just watch that you know today is
a huge day for tomorrow right now it's
happening they started their first
padded practice of the summer at 9 30
this morning so you need before you get
off the air to get an update of how
Demar Hamlin did in that practice
because it will be the first time in
exactly 30 weeks
that he hit somebody in a violent way
now is he going to be always thinking
about that moment on an absolutely
average tackle of T Higgins is he going
to be thinking of that moment when he uh
lowers his shoulder into Dawson Knox
this morning you know so it's going to
be interesting to watch Peter King's
upcoming visits to Camp the Eagles
Ravens Dolphins Falcons Panthers Pete
safe travels as always great to have you
back thanks for joining us
that's Peter King the football morning
in America columnist will take a break
our best and worst of the weekend right
after this